[Musique]
ur pourzer vos mer vre jardin ça fait
peur au voisin qu'est-ce qu'il veutain
[Musique]
je vois pas pourquoi il y a pas de
raison 1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ce coup-ci on va tester un jeu sur
une console sur laquelle j'ai énormément
joué mais aussi paradoxalement sur celle
où il me reste le moins de jeu parce que
j'en ai prêté plein sans jamais les
revoir la Playstation alors bon est-ce
que la Playstation est une console rétro
oui et non on va dire c'est la console
qui a marqué le début vers la nouvelle
génération alors déjà elle a mis tout le
monde d'accord sur la fameuse guerre des
consoles entre Nintendo et Sega en
éclpsant totalement la Saturne qui après
ça ne s'en relèvera jamais elle a marqué
le début véritable du support CD qui a
permis l'introduction de cinématique et
de jeux plus complets le début du
piratage aussi mais aussi surtout elle a
eu un catalogue de jeux incroyable qui
nous ont tous marqué Final Fantasy 7
Tomb Raider Destruction Derby teken il y
en a trop pour les cités il y a vraiment
trop de bon jeux virus rien que le nom
vous voyez déjà ça laisse présager de la
[Musique]
suite ah ça en fait remonter des
souvenirs ce petit jingle maintenant je
me pose une question quand on adapte un
bon film en jeu ça donne un truc tout
pourri donc qu'est-ce qui se passerait
si on adoptait un mauvais film en jeu
[Musique]
il est puissant il a trouvé une planète
idéale à
conquérir il est
intellig dans l'univ maintenant
iluire
exist virus
donc le scénario c'est de la foudre
extraterrestre qui tombe sur terre et
transmet un virus dans l'électricité qui
transforme les gens en robot zombies a
que scénario pareil ça peut êtreénorme
virus care sorti en 1999 développé par
les petits français de cRIO
interactive le scénario est juste énorme
on dirait que ça a été écrit par un
enfant de 5 ans quoi tout a commencé
dans le bateau et puis maintenant c'est
dans l'hôtel mais nul ne sait comment
mais si même eux ils le savent pas nous
on risque pas de le savoir mais je capte
pas comment ils ont pu sortir ça quoi
allez Kevin tu nous l ta réaction et ben
c'est un méchant virus qui est vilain et
puis il y a des policiers viennent les
détruire et puis
voilà gamin le but du niveau c'est donc
d'aller jusqu'à l'hôtel et va savoir
pourquoi pour ça on passe par les égouts
alors égou qui ressemble d'ailleurs plus
un vaisseau extraterrestre mais bon
passon allonsy pour le niveau 1
ou
ou c'est moche ah c'est vraiment très
très moche pourlacer ça dans le contexte
en 1999 Tom Raider éta sorti depuis 2
ans Resident Evil depuis 3 ans vraiment
aucune excuse pour sortir un truc
auss alors le jeu donc c'est un jeu de
tir à la trè personne vous contrôlez j
une policière de profession agent de la
paix avant tout alors oui c'est une
femme on dirait une religieuse vu la
forme des jambes mais c'est une femme
avance tout ce qui arrive que ce soit
des zombies
ou ou d'autres
trucs ah mais c'est génial mais c'est la
fête je me suis fait démembrer mais
méchant complètement démembrer regardez
ça mais là je précise je précise quand
même que je joue depuis 30 secondes
c'est la 3è salle du jeu et je suis déjà
mort tu es par je sais pas tout tout est
tellement moche dans ce jeu c'est
difficile de dire ce qu' vous tu
voil regarde ça le game over il est
magnifique par contre là c'est la plus
belle chose que j'ai vu depuis le début
du jeu
ouais bon
allez
[Musique]
allez quand même un truc qui me manque
pas sur la Playstation c'est quand même
l'ét de chargement je dire autant quand
tu joues un bon jeu ça va mais quand tu
joues à virus là je te jure que c'est
lour
d'attendre allez c'est bon scénario ça
va je peux pas passer S
fou vous savez je suis en train
d'essayer de me souvenir là mais
j'arrive pas à me rappeler d'un jeu
comme virus tu ne ramasses aucun item il
y a absolument rien il y a pas de J
barbal il y a pas d'arme à ramasser pas
de M a rien il y a pas d'itemada que
d c'est une vraé chure à diriger ce jeu
on dirait que tu joues une policière on
dirait une androgine et une anorexique
tu pourrais croire qu' serait un minimum
souple à diriger mais non c'est tu la
diriges que un [ __ ] de camion ben
il y a bien un bouton qui permet de
changer d'angle mais en plein combat
bonne
chance oh [ __ ] mais qu'est-ce que
c'est mais je suis poursuivi par un Big
Mac avec des pattes mais lâche-moi
lâche-moi
non allez tourne tournetin mais je te
jure j'ai l'impression contrôler un
pétrolier quoi allez tourne-toi mais
[ __ ] c'est incroyable
oh a un bouton pourer mais il est
pratiquement inutile que dès que vous
l'utilisez là ta gourdass elle arrive
plus à viser les enem regardez ça mais
ça fait 3 minutes qu'on tourne en rond
comme des idiots [ __ ] c'est pas
possible espè de N à côté pourquoi tu
tires sur le M fait je rve de regardez
la Tron qui lui mais c'est quoi le manè
enchant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un jeu comme ça tu es obligé de le
comparer à la référence de l'époque en
terme de maniabilité c'estàdire Tom
Raider quand tu tournais autour d'un
ennemi avec Lara le verrouillage des
cibles était 1000 fois plus expcace même
si le truc était pas en face de toi là
dans virus il y a un ce minuscule devant
toi où tu touch tes cibles et dès
qu'elles sortent c'est fini tu touches
plus
fa chier c'est pas
[Musique]
vrai et sans déconnait sur la trentaine
de personnes qui faisaient ce jeu je
suis sûr que tu en avais 20 qui
faisaient la cinématique d'intro H qui
faisaient un game over magnifique et
deux qui se cassaient le cul à faire le
reste du jeu en
entier ah oui il y a un truc dont j'ai
pas parlé c'est que vous êtes pas seul
vous avez un équipier qui s'appelle
Suter et ce mec c'est vraiment un [ __ ]
de figurant c'est il a pareil au début
pour tirer dans le mur après il
disparaît on le revoit plus du tout
jusqu'à la fin du niveau une fois que le
boss a été battu en fait vous apprenez
qu'il était bloqué comme un con et qu'il
arrivait pas à ouvrir la porte
parti P le ou quoi tu FEM je te jure
hein con c'est quoi ce bruit là niveau 2
maintenant c'est pas très rassuran tout
ça non sérieux oh il y a pas de quoi
ben voilà il fallait bien que ça arrive
comme tout cliché de film d'horreur on
est que deux on est dans un hôtel rempli
de zombies a du sang partout sur les mur
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on se sépare voyons
ah ouais d'accord en fait on se sépare
ça veut dire lui reste là pour se
toucher et moi je vais chercher
l'ascenseur ah je te rapporte un café
aussi au niveau du son les bruitages
sont catastrophiques que ce soit pour
les armes pour les zombies qui font sans
arrêt le même bruit pour mademoiselleos
auss franchementend à force de
l'entendre crier comme une autruche ça
devient super
saoulant c'est un peu méchant mais sent
qu'ils ont quand même essayé de faire
des efforts je veux dire vous savez des
fois il y a la caméra qui s'en va sans
prévenir pour se placer à 200 m de toi
quand tu entres dans une salle pour te
dire que es des zombies qui arriv
Resident Evil faisait beaucoup ce genre
de chose mais c'était bien fait quoi
alors que là ben
voilà [ __ ] c'est vraiment dégueulasse
regardez les décor il pas de [ __ ] le
camp il y a pas une seule ligne droiteù
on voyit pas des pixels de la taille de
mon point et quand même quand les persos
il bougent pas on dirait qu'ils ont des
spasmes ce jeu est sorti 5 mois après
metalger solide mais là graphiquement
mais il a des années et des années de
retard en général dans les jeux tirés de
film la majorité du pognon passe dans
l'achat de la licence mais là e me dites
pas que la licence virus a vidé les
caisses franchement quoi là c'est juste
que ça a été codé n'importe comment ou
par n'importe qui je sais pas j'achète
votre fil TR la bcherie mar je m'en fous
je m'en fous je veux rien savoir B un
café un café et vous achetez des pour ma
femme j'ai pas de femme trouvez-moi une
femme et vous vous avez programmé le jeu
de virus pour
moi fa sû que vous étiez l'homme de la
situation niveau 3 chaque nouveau niveau
c'est l'occasion de rigoler un peu plus
là vous savez je rencontre un agent de
sécurité et cur et lui décide de rester
là pour garder la salle vide pendant que
moi je vais faire le fait leur
place c'est vraiment une sale manie que
ces zombies onent toujours tombé du
plafond sérieux en fait il y a un truc
qui vous sauve à chaque fois que les
ennemis vous tombent dessus c'est que le
jeu il est tellement mal codé
i ben non si si je suis désolé le jeu
est tellement mal codé que dès que tu
croises un peu de monde tu as les FPS
qui chutent à mort le jeu qui se met à
tourner au ralenti et le seul bon côté
c'est que ça rend le truc faisable en
fait vous voyez regardez ça dès que les
ennemis sont morts les FPS reviennent à
la normal virus a inventé le boulet time
dans les jeux vidéos 2 ans MaxP enfin
bon grâce à ça au moins on a tout le
tempsadmirer les superbes ennemis du
jeu mais regardez-moi ça mais qu'est-ce
que
c'est bon fait les zombies c'est censé
faire peur on dirait le carnaval
[Musique]
dece et puis là je suis à parler des
ennemis les développeurs se sont même
pas fait chier à faire mourir certains
ennemis quand vous les tuer ils
disparaissent d'un coup comme ça allez
hop c'est aussi bidon que josephineange
gardien et pour vous dire mais à quel
point il sont flemars mais prenez les
mot de passes des niveaux ils se
terminent tous par trois triangles c'est
c'est comme s'ils avaient eu la flemme
de faire un truc complet et puis
d'ailleurs merde ça me gaveave là j'ai
même pas envie de continuer ce jeu c'est
vraiment trop pourri donc je vais aller
direct au dernier niveau allez
hop allez regarde-moi le scénario il
faut détruire le mal [ __ ] de glandeur
de scénarist quoi c'est eux qu' faudrait
détruire
plutôt mais regardez les côtés quoi il y
a les murs qui s'évaporent quand
j'avance qu c'est génial là tu sens
c'est le dernier niveau les mecs les
programmeurs ils étaient à bout de force
ils ont dû se dire c'est bon vas-y on
s'en bat le steak de ce jeu de toute
façon personne l'achètera notre jeu de
merde alors dépêche bacler ça que je
puisse rentrer chez moi et puis Bast
et allez revoilà les big non [ __ ] non
mais mais quel intérêt de te montrer ça
si c'est inévitable [ __ ] oh non mais
quelle merde je te jure quoi [ __ ] mais
non mais c'est pas possible que il y en
a encore allez moià c'est bon là j'en
peux plus j'arrête je vous jure en fait
vous savez je vous ai pas tout montré
mais ce jeu est pas juste mauvais ce jeu
c'est c'est le mal en fait c'est si
j'avais réussi à aller jusqu'au boss de
fa je suis sûr que le boss de fa mais
mais ça aurait été la boîte du je
lui-même quoi vous savez virus
finalement c'est pas plus mal que le
film a fait un flop parce que si ça
avait marché on aurait eu une twite on
aurait eu d'autres jeux vidéos et vu la
catastrophe atomique qui a été le
premier là je préfère même pas imaginer
la suite
quoi dans le
passé le mal a été vaincu
mais pas
complètement le mal est de
retour et il va
faire mal et merde qui CRR ça CIT un
virus qui se transmet par sonore et qui
transforme les gens en zombie de Francis
Lalan de
l'action du suspense
alors qu'est-ce que je vais manger à
mini des titres qui vont très vite vers
la caméra virus
2 ce film ça va être une bombe et on va
en faire un jeu et c'est toi qui va le
programmer coco
[Musique]